[Музика]
можливо, waha моніторинг, ймовірно,
Astoria більше з Cecily totora в них
Natasha's the chest microswitch na Brasa
freesias yet, чувак,
привіт, хлопці, мене звуть Наталія, ходімо
, пора уроку англійської мови, почнемо
сьогодні, я хотів би привітати свою
любу  гість привіт Лена привіт Наталія як справи
сьогодні дякую
я добре я радий тебе і я
теж радий тебе бачити
давайте розпочнемо урок так добре ми
продовжимо розмову про літературу і
сьогодні ми додамо трохи  граматика, то моє
улюблене запитання, чи подобається тобі бабуся, ні
чому, тому що мені легше говорити,
я бачу, так що я Джим, щоб писати, а потім йому
писати добре, тому це буде
комбінація трохи мовлення та
трохи граматики та  ви робите з нами,
тож давайте спочатку перевіримо домашнє завдання.
Я попросив вас написати параграф
про книгу, тож давайте подивимося на
різні книги та переглянемо типи
книг, тож, як ви думаєте, Ліна, це
тип книги «Зоряні війни»
детектив Роман  що це за фантастичний
детектив так, фентезі чи наукова
фантастика, тому що азіатська наукова фантастика
добре зроблено, а що щодо Шерлока Холмса,
це детектив, і я думаю, що це детектив, і я думаю, що
трохи історичний, добре, а що щодо книг про Гаррі
Поттера ні, це дивовижна історія
включає магію так,
це пригодницька історія  коли ви говорите про
пригоди, багато пригод, ви
також можете сказати, що це фантастична книга,
добре, якщо ми подивимося на цю книгу
Єлизавета Королева, як ви думаєте, що
це за книга, це фантастична книга, ні, добре,
це бестселер New York Times, який я щойно
прочитав  добре, отже, це книга про
дуже відомого моніка, так, Елізабет II, так,
корона, так, зернові, земля, так,
це книга з біографією, біографія, давайте
повторимо біографію, біографію, молодець, тож
давайте подивимося на параграф,
репортаж — це книга-пригодницька книга
написана Джоном Ролліном, це історія
про молодого чарівника та його друзів, які
борються з темним чарівником, а тепер давайте,
був інший варіант подивіться
маленькі жінки
то що це за книга, це добре,
це класичний роман, добре зроблено, що
щодо автора, добре, так давайте перевіримо
разом
, подивіться «Маленькі жінки» — класичний
роман, його написала Луїза Мей Олкотт,
це історія чотирьох сестер та
їхнього життя  від дитинства до жіночого
віку ви читали історію «Маленькі жінки»
ні, але я збираюся читати добре, а як
ви дивитеся фільм ні, ще немає,
вам точно потрібно його подивитися,
це дуже гарна історія, невідомо, добре, давайте
так далі  настав час граматики,
давайте поглянемо на речення з «Маленьких жінок»
ще раз подивіться «Маленькі жінки»,
написане Луїзою Мей
Олкотт  з бабусею
сьогодні представляємо простий презент безперервна
форма gerrant що як ви хочете добре,
дуже дякую, тому подивіться на
цю конкретну частину написана, тому я
впевнений, що деякі з вас уже
здогадалися, що ми будемо говорити
про батька  ssive voice у нас є речення в
активному та пасивному, тож давайте сьогодні поговоримо
про ці дві речі,
але Сідней закінчив ммм-хм добре, давайте
йти далі, тому пасивний залог поглянь
на це речення садівник
поливав квіти щодня, щоб у нас була
тема
vicuna з d садівник і ми
маємо дієслово dia поливати це так садівник
поливати це що він
поливав подивіться об'єкт надіак у кутку
це Jia квіти, тому садівник
поливав квіти це активний голос
активність tan let
подивіться на передавання, тому ми
змінюємо речення подивіться суб'єкт
потурання дорогий стає агентом, тому
садівник дія є більш важливою тут, дорогий
Білл Швоз Рівер Мітч Макконнелл, так
що об'єкт стає суб'єктним об'єктом,
тепер вони прийшли вважати  це gia stay
yahoo long name Trenholm retina, тому він
стає пігментним предметом її погляду
квітами, де вода це тому, що це
в минулому біля саду, я знову дивлюся
активний v  ой, садівник
поливав квіти, я можу повторити, будь ласка,
садівнику, які квіти,
велике дякую і пасивний голос
квіти поливав садівник
квіти поливав
садівник поливав садівник дуже дякую
давайте подивимося на це  малюнок, щоб діти
щось роблять, що ти
думаєш, що вони роблять
Лена, я думаю, я думаю, що вони
працюють  діти чи
клубний клуб важливіше те, що вони
хочуть організувати дуже велику компанію, тому
ці студенти
знову створили Клуб переробки
відходів  давайте подивимося інший
приклад подивіться, у нас є панда, і ми
говорили про різні фільми, тому
документальний фільм про панд знову документальний фільм
важливіший власник
документа  tary не важливо, ми
цікавимось фільмом, тому документальний фільм
про панд було знято минулого місяця, чи можете
ви повторити документальний фільм про панда,
знятий минулого місяця так, дуже дякую,
тож давайте подивимося на
формулу дієслова to be плюс частки минулого I  Я
збираюся помістити це на дошці, щоб
ви запам’ятали під час уроку, добре, тому ми
говоримо про два часи тут:
теперішній і минулий, якщо ми подивимося на
дієслово to be в простому теперішньому часі,
які форми нагадує мені Лана  to be
to be him так наше Браво дуже
дякую давайте запишемо
це добре, гм так
наше це для теперішнього часу що
щодо минулого Ліна дієслово to be for
the past was worth GABA дуже
дякую давайте запишемо це
так і добре, так що ми скажемо було і
добре, яка різниця була використання
зазвичай використовуйте з I і was I і він вона
це
для огляду добре, щоб ми могли сказати, що було
для однини однини would Nana Doudna
me and were lamb no johnny was and  ну
як щодо па  st частка what's this
ми можемо просто сказати, що це те саме, що
і слово в третій формі причастка минулого часу
чи пам'ятаєте ви, що знаєте дієприкметник минулого часу,
ваші правильні дієслова, ми зазвичай
говоримо правильно mhm трохи боляче, тому давайте
попрацюємо над формуванням, як ми складаємо
речення так  ми говорили про сьогодення М - це
наше минуле було давайте подивимося
на стверджувальні речення що це
ствердне Ленна пам'ятаю
ствердне ні я не я не пам'ятаю
це позитивне речення віртуальний
оповідач чи можете ви вгадати негативне це,
мабуть, схоже на Фермата  так негативне
негативне нестор так
окремий енергетичний запитальний, як
ви думаєте, чи є інший, так що якщо у нас є
позитивний негатив і немає
процедури так заппа терпить
запитальний,
то давайте подивимося
активний голос у нас вони посадили дерева
не просто, і тепер нам потрібно змінити  це
в пасивний пасив, подивіться,
дерева були посаджені добре, тому ми маємо
дієслово to be плюс дієприкметник минулого часу,
давайте подивимося на заперечне речення, яке
вони зробили  не планую, Лінна, чи можеш ти прочитати, що
дерева пасивного голосу не були посаджені так,
тому ми просто додаємо не це дуже легко,
і щоб поставити запитання чи
запитати, що нам потрібно зробити так, ми
поставили експонат на початку
речення так чи вони посадили дерева активний
та пасивний залог Ханна,
будь ласка, допоможіть мені, будь ласка, чи були посаджені дерева
чудово, дуже дякую, тому давайте
розглянемо інший приклад книгу,
наприклад, я читав книгу це
теперішній час Ніна, ви можете допомогти  я з
заперечним реченням я не читаю в я
не читаю книгу добре і
питання чи я читав книгу добре це
збирається зробити я роблю добре давайте підемо з
пасивним залогом я читаю книгу давайте зробимо це
пасивним залогом  вони не написали читати ага
О, читай добре давайте спробуємо слово,
буде легше давайте запишемо їх
добре, тому я, перш за все, книга була
правильною ага
читаю я читаю я читаю книгу добре,
тепер давайте змінимо це е-  ага книга книга
була, якщо вона є ми не чіпаємо передати
я читаю добре так  правильно читати добре третя
форма я пам'ятаю так, книга це книга читається
мною добре, або книга читається, просто
давайте зробимо це в минулому, щоб я прочитав
книгу, і пасивним голосом для
минулого буде я  книга була прочитана
фантастично книга була прочитана давайте повторимо
добре і лемма книга була прочитана фантастично
дуже багато я знаю, що повторення може
бути нудним правильно добре давайте потренуємося чи
можете ви сказати, що книгу читали
дуже голосно книгу читали книгу  було
прочитано добре уявіть, що ви присягаєте
своїх дітей через найрозумнішого чоловіка сьогодні,
книгу прочитали добре, тепер ви дуже
милий ви здивовані, що у вас є
фантастичний подарунок, і ви дуже милий
мою книгу прочитали фантастично,
дуже дякую, давайте рухатися  на у нас є
завдання подивіться п'ять речень і нам
потрібно додати дієслово to be в теперішньому часі і
в минулому have a look we have is our
woes and two times we need to add work
mm-hmm
have a look and get  готові перевірити разом
з нами, давайте разом перевіримо
номер один  Яна, як ти думаєш,
що буде правильною відповіддю Я думаю, що
нам потрібно використовувати легкість, о, парк
відвідують сотні туристів
щодня, так, це правильно, чому ви
вважаєте, що нам потрібно використовувати теперішнє,
тому що я  бачив кожен день добре кожен день
багато допомагає нам кожен день це
пускові слова для теперішнього просто добре
зроблено
чому ви вибрали східний вузол R, тому
що парк добре
однина молодець давайте з номером
два було відкрито два нових притулку для тварин
були відкриті в понеділок
так були відкриті минулого понеділка, чому не були
наші, тому що минулого понеділка добре, і тому що
притулки притулки це множина
молодець номер три статуї Парфенону
були розроблені Сідіусом
добре зроблено знову статуї статуї
добре, і це було в минулому
так, частини не знаю, де знаходиться  людина
на сцені
так, нісенітниця в Греції, тому в
Акрополі там є священик, давайте підемо
з номером чотири Тадж-Махал Тадж-
Махал був побудований в 17 столітті
правильно
Браво у вас є те саме  відповідай давайте
йти чому у нас війни чому у нас це
було тому, що це було в 17 столітті так
самотньо так давно давно померли і
далеко
далеко Галапагоські острови щороку відвідувало
багато людей добре
подивіться о ми маємо  щороку щороку
я дурний ти не так, ти повинен бути
ти маєш бути дуже уважним,
шукай слова в реченні, які можуть
тобі допомогти, тож ходімо далі, у мене є
завдання для вас подивіться у нас
різні  дієслова, і нам потрібно розділити
їх на дві групи regular travel need
is wala irregular no prevali in this
lava, так що просто розділіть їх на дві групи,
добре, дайте вам 15 секунд, давайте
добре, тож давайте перевіримо,
давайте почнемо зі звичайних дієслів, що, на
вашу думку,  звичайний Lina Bank pack okay
in past simple причастя минулого часу
збирається бути упакований упакований Браво добре наступне
одне слово добре і past simple
boarded good що це означає нудно
нудьгувати так це означає йти на літак
так, щоб на посадку, щоб пасажири  є
б  oarded okay і разом з цим
відвідайте yes and the past visited Java, тому
перевірте, будь ласка, чи є у вас те саме
, це регулярні дієслова let's go with
irregular, так що всі інші є неправильними,
але давайте переглянемо минулий дієприкметник на
неправильний, тому я думаю, що це допоможе мені
третя форма коду catch catch коду
Браво чи
можете ви повторити код catch коду Bravo
gonna catch code коду дивовижно, тож давайте
запишемо це дуже цікаве
слово, ви його напишіть і побачите тьфу T, але
ви вимовляєте його як цитату добре виконано
наступне
дайте  отримай Браво ммм-хм навіть добре
аромат аромат чудовий тут
боляче боляче добре і залишимо ліворуч
фантастичним, тож давайте перевіримо ще раз упаковану
дошку, яку він відвідав і розрізав, оскільки пісок боляче
і залишилося добре Селіна Я хотів би, щоб ви
створили власне речення, використовуючи
неправильні дієслова, наприклад with the
world send what can be
sent send a letter yes so a letterbox box
let's make a passive voice sentence
in the passive a letter was sent to my
sister
okay to my  сестра легко молодець, тому
давайте підемо зі світом, залишивши те, що можна
залишити вдома, наприклад, громадянам
нашої країни залишилася війна, залишена вдома
на чотири місяці, що ж, це дуже
цікаве речення, тому громадяни
повинні були залишитися проблемою добре  добре
мій мій собака добре
залишився вдома добре залишився вдома
щодня добре він залишився вдома кожен день все
добре
іди сам привіт бідна бідна собака
добре давайте йти далі подивимося на
структуру це дуже цікава
модель у нас є приголосний дуже
висока вежа Wawel huis na коротка
година, потім знову приголосний і
знову коливання так приголосний голосний
приголосний голосний і я прошу вас зробити
мозковий штурм якомога більше повторів,
дотримуючись цієї моделі як приклад,
візьміть, а інші я даю вам 15 секунд,
добре
Тож давайте разом перевіримо лимон, чи можете ви
допомогти мені, ми маємо правильно поглинати так,
заощадити добре, мати фантастичну ненависть так добре
ненавиджу, любов, так
добре, гм, гм, гм, м'ясо Шанель мм-хм,
молодець, у
вас є власний список, який можна б  Це
дуже довгий список, тож давайте спробуємо з
іншою моделлю, подивіться на цю,
щоб у нас була приголосна голосна, а
потім приголосна, як-от кухар або м’ясо, тому
я знову даю вам 15 секунд,
запишіть слово готове до перевірки,
давайте так  we have koukin mates
lincoler допоможіть мені з більше слів читати
молодець Люк Люк добре мм-хм
тут добре так книга книга що ми можемо забронювати
це дієслово не іменник
хм книга ми можемо забронювати готель так о ми
можемо забронювати готель  готель подивіться
квитки, щоб вийти першим
так добре що ще так я роблю це зазвичай
добре
де де де добре зроблено
і це зараз
очищається мені це подобається так він робить це означає, що я
люблю їсти банани, тому коли я беру
банан, я очищаю банан що  інакше ми можемо
почистити, але вона сьогодні купила, добре,
що ще ми можемо почистити картоплю, картоплю. Телевізор
добре,
чоловік, ти можеш спалити, ти можеш покласти моркву,
фантастично, дуже дякую, тому
для вас сьогодні нові турботи
очистіть добре, тепер спробуйте скласти речення,
використовуючи кілька  з цих слів, наприклад,
хм, книга i  беремо за приклад «okay»
або візьмемо слово «готувати»,
тож ми збираємось
створити якомога більше речень,
використовуючи модель подивіться у
нас є суб’єкти дієслова та агент
агент використовується як суб’єкт у активному  голос
тепер став легендою, тож Лена для
тебе буде легше, тому у нас є
різні теми, як-от історія
подарунок гаманець що таке гаманець гаманець
гаманець
давай давай це добре торт
мм-хм банан книжка добре  що ще я
запустив автомобіль добре, так що це
теми для вас, будь ласка, у мене також є
дієслова, тож давайте перевіримо разом, ми
прочитали PU
я маю право мити, дайте взяти випікати, чи знаєте ви
слово "спекти випікати торт"
слова для вас молодці, а тепер нам
потрібно створити дію, людина, яка
це робить, і тут у мене є порожній простір,
тому ви збираєтеся створити своїх власних
агентів, це може бути Мадонна, я не
знаю президента, добре, чому б і ні
тож ви давайте запишемо тут вісім
різних агентів fo  r дії це
можуть бути випадкові люди будь-хто інший
кожен, кого ви хочете, добре,
тому давайте напишемо разом, сер
ручка для вас, у мене є ручка, тож давайте візьмемо
так, агентів, це може бути
старший з Глазго, побачите
мене  дзвонив я знаю, що це не так, ПОКАЙ,
МАМО, до побачення, моя мама, добре, і ти можеш писати
з нами, тому напиши мені вісім різних
агентів, напиши мені добре, тварини, тварини,
добре, до побачення,
Меріл Стріп добре, моя улюблена актриса
, це приємно, я теж її люблю,
мої діти, добре мм  -хм, чоловік добре,
хто є чоловіком, ви можете згадати мій мій
мій чоловік мій чоловік добре
ммм я думаю, малюк, президент
зненацька, я не в порядку мм-хм, пан.
президент, готуйся, і перша
леді, яка перша леді, добре, так
що подивіться, як приклад
Ленні Кравіц їсть облігації,
мені подобається в булочках, але так, але я роблю це не
часто, добре, тому якщо це речення
безпристрасне, давайте зробимо  це активним голосом,
тому перш за все гурти будуть
в кінці речення, щоб вони
стали об'єктом.
Добре, а як ми придумали Ленні
Кравіц, давайте зробимо
це підметом, щоб нам не потрібно було використовувати  ми
використовуємо Lana okay,
а дієслово then let's змінимо дієслово
are eaten на активний залог у
теперішньому простому Liana its bonds every day
так добре, це буде мрія Liana, її
зв'язки щодня добре, я також люблю їсти булочки
, і це але це  було б і моєю
мрією, тому ми збираємося написати
два типи речень
пасивного та активного, добре, давайте йти далі, тому
це приклад, щоб ви пам'ятали,
Ленна, давайте почнемо брати по одному шматочку з
кожної чашки мм-хм і давайте створимо
речення  це буде випадковим чином, і ви
пишете dow  n у нас подарунок
дарує перша леді
добре, це гарне речення, давайте запишемо
його подарунок робить перша
леді, давайте зробимо його активним голосом
перша леді дарує подарунок, дякую,
давайте з наступним  один хм добре
хмм торт забирають тварини добре, так що
торт зникне, давайте запишемо його
торт забрали тварини, будь ласка,
запишіть речення активним голосом, тоді я
допоможу мені, тварини беруть торт, беруть торт, добре,
давайте, було інакше,
добре  книжка випечена моєю мамою фантастично,
тому книгу випікала мама Ліни, це
цікаво,
це смішне речення, але це
можливо, книгу
випікає моя мама, чи я напишу мама Ліни чи моя мама моя мама
моя мама так, ймовірно, вона збирається
спекти пиріг у формі книжки у
формі добре виглядати давайте ще одним
реченням цікавим так банан все
гаразд О, що
написано мною мною так, мабуть, слово
банан написано тобою добре давайте
банан  написано мною ммм добре так л  ast
one на сьогодні так, так, гаманець
миє президент президент
так пан.  президент як часто ви
миєте гаманець добре, давайте запишемо,
її гаманець випраний, тому під час
карантину нам потрібно дуже часто дезінфікувати наш гаманець,
тому це нормально,
а президент без грошей,
як щодо активного голосу
за це речення президент
вимитий миє миє гаманець фантастичний чи
можете ви, будь ласка, складіть речення в
минулому подарунок подарувала перша
леді торт забрали тварини
книгу спекла моя мама добре мій банан
написав я добре писав
написано гаманець  було вимито
президентом фантастичне дякую,
тому ми продовжуємо ваше домашнє завдання, я б попросила
вас написати речення в минулому
простому, що Лена щойно оголосила, але
вам потрібно їх записати, візьміть телефон,
сфотографуйте речення і
спробував їх на наступному уроці,
і вони чують дзвінок, це означає,
що нам потрібно припинити урок, Лена,
тобі сподобався урок так, дуже дякую,
це була моя перевернута пригода до моєї
дитинство
добре дякую дуже дякую побачимося наступного
разу до побачення, свіжий камінь Buju
класу зараз зроби - зачекай машину, але це
пікап з шоковою кочергою з ключовим ключем
так круто схожий він переслідує лайно
LM знаючи Apple Венеція Казахська солома
Meister  туманний професіоналізм acutally
знову Mr.  barrini
[Музика]
ти